the third plate came off of research
about the history of our food culture
and what I came to realize is that is
that we have a pretty bad history when
it comes to food culture and and really
what that means is that we eat off of
this or we have been eating off of what
I was calling the first plate which is
which is a protein centric plate of food
it's a it's a it's a steak a seven ounce
steak with a little bit of vegetable a
bit of grain on the side but essentially
it's a protein take center stage and the
second plate as I described in in in my
book is is sort of we've come out of the
first plate and enter the second plate
with is farm-to-table movement like the
good food movement is is really about
knowing where your ingredients come from
so so the steak is now grass-fed and the
vegetables are are organic and the grain
is you know instead of white rice it's
whole grains but the problem with the
second plate is that it looks very much
like the first plate the architecture is
the same so while it's a better plate of
food gastronomically it's better and
from an environmental perspective it's
better the the architecture dictates a
kind of carrying capacity that the land
can't support at least in our region it
can't support very long for a growing
population for a cuisine or for a
pattern of eating you know two times a
day seven days a week to expect that
kind of Architecture from our diets is a
huge expectation and to export that diet
to the rest of the world the Western
diet the Emeritus really the American
diet is is unfortunate and also the true
definition of not sustainable
so the third plate is sort of a way to
to kind of circle out of that and take
the progress of knowing where our
ingredients come from but by changing
the architecture and looking at looking
at a plate of food not so much as what
we expect from our lunch or dinner but
what is the land telling us it can
provide and then figuring out a cuisine
a pattern of eating that response
landscape and actually improves
landscape the best farm scapes the best
farmlands
in any region are always about an
abundance of diversity those are the
healthiest landscapes because because in
a natural setting there's no such thing
as a monoculture is no such thing as
lack of diversity in fact the world a
natural environment is defined by its
diversity even the most severe divide
environments and so what we need to do
is as eaters because as eaters we are
disrupting a natural food system a
natural system any natural system
domestication is about disruption of a
natural system and and the the art in
eating and the art and cooking in the
art and farming all three the
correspondence of all three is really
about disrupting that natural landscape
thoughtfully and with with a thought to
the future how can it not only be
disrupted but disrupted well so that it
improves the ecological conditions and
functioning of nature and doesn't take
away from it that's really the true
definition of sustainability how do we
think about improving ecological
function water use diversity life both
in the soil and above the soil diversity
of life it's always about diversity so
one surefire way to encourage that is to
eat with a diverse plate so if you're
cooking at home by the way if you're
cooking at home you're already doing a
lot because it means somebody else isn't
cooking for you and someone else cooks
for you it generally means that they're
cooking less delicious food and they're
cooking food that's less good for you
because usually when we process food we
end up de neuting it and ending it in
ways that go beyond just health it just
flavor as well so the best thing you can
do is cook your own food and then the
second best thing you can do is